avec la baisse des dotations de l'État
quel avenir pour la culture dans les
ivelines mercredi 30 mars à l'ESTACA de
Montini le Bretonneux le département a
fait une présentation de ses
orientations culturelles pour les années
à venir une réunion qui faisait suite
aux journées d'échang décembre dernier
entre élus locaux et acteurs culturels
on a dû réfléchir bien sûr pour ne pas
abandonner la culture parce que c'est
pas du tout notre principe et c'est
surtout on a très envie au contraire
d'accompagner et bien de mettre en place
des dispositifs qui sont des disposis
je dirais qui demande plus de
participation plus d'échanges et de
nouveautés et de remise en question
peut-être directeur de théâtre metteur
en scène et élu du territoire plus d'une
centaine de personnes ont assisté à
cette rencontre l'objectif pour le
département réaffirmer son engagement
pour la culture et présenter les
différentes solutions imaginées il a par
exemple lancé un appel à projet afin de
soutenir le développement culturell et
les initiatives les plus prometteuses la
problématique c'est simplement la
méthode aujourd'hui du du partage que
l'on doit faire entre les différents
territoires pour continuer d'accompagner
la culture quand vous voyez l'État la
Région le Département les
intercommunalités et les collectivités
chacun devra retrouver une place qui est
la sienne pour pouvoir repositionner un
équilibre on est vraiment en train de
dessiner ce que sera le spectacle vivant
dans les 10 dans les 15 ans à venir pour
moi la question c'est à moyen
terme d'avoir un un paysage relativement
sur plan culturel après étude des
candidatures le versement de l'aide pour
les projets commencera en septembre de
nouvelles réunions auront lieu dans les
prochains mois pour concrétiser les
différents dispositifs imaginés par le
département